marketing has all changed and is
constantly follow de broodhuys comes
digital ensorhuis marketing at chili en je
wat 17 trillion dollars in i was
alone with bent om digital marketing and
that data again partner we de leaders after
relocation and social media prepare
you for granted show  marketing digital
marketing allah here and lies creativity
www murders the marketing services
bible in my arms die nds google 15
16 years me neither this heart my
marketing klaas the holy grail is right
person right time by pressing the
internet is that could not be fun  found
actually medical and edward hi-macs arie
wait who wants the quick degree program
to teach you do for a job digital
marketing skills of search social media
display advertising
email marketing and a drugs and the mind
most amazing awesome and then takes part
i  in the course
there that search in google partner
to is that you get down a [ __ ] need the
cabbage we veriac boring the what is program'
in my  wheels looking forward to see my
students mars mercurius in digital
marketing
[Music]
[Applause]